>>> WELCOME BACK TO CNN'S LIVE
SPECIAL COVERAGE.
EIGHT, COUNT THEM, ONE, TWO,
THREE, FOUR, FIVE, SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT, PUBLIC HUMILIATIONS FOR
REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY, COURTESY OF THE
REPUBLICAN REBELS IN HIS OWN
CAUCUS.
THIS IS THE UNCHANGING FACE OF
THE OPPOSITION, 20 MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO HAVE REPEATEDLY
SAID NO TO MAKING McCARTHY THE
LEADER OF THE NEW REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE, PUTTING
HIM A FEW HEARTBEATS AWAY FROM
THE PRESIDENCY.
LET'S GET OVER TO JOHN KING WHO
HAS AGREED TO TAKE A STROLL OVER
TO TELL US WHO THESE 20 MEN AND
WOMEN ARE.
>> Reporter: WE SEE THEM ON THE
FLOOR AND LET'S MAP OUT AND SHOW
WHERE THEY COME FROM.
AND WHY THEY MIGHT THINK THIS
MIGHT HURT THEM POLITICALLY BACK
HOME.
THERE ARE 222 HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S A NET GAIN OF TEN FROM
THE ELECTION THAT WAS JUST SHY
OF 60 DAYS AGO.
DEMOCRATS' 213 HERE, AND THE
NUMBER IS 212 BECAUSE ONE PASSED
AWAY AFTER THE ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE DOWN TO 212.
YOU MENTIONED WHO ARE THESE
HOLDOUTS?
IF YOU COUNT SPARTZ OF INDIANA,
SHE HAS VOTED PRESENT.
THESE OTHERS HAVE VOTED FOR
OTHER CANDIDATES, AND AS YOU CAN
SEE GEOGRAPHICALLY, IT'S A
DIVERSE MIX.
THEY'RE REPUBLICANS FROM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IF IT'S DEEP RED, THAT MEANS
THEY WON COMFORTABLY.
IF IT'S MORE OF A PINK, THAT
MEANS THEY WERE RELATIVELY CLOSE
RACES.
LAUREN BOEBERT STANDS OUT AMONG
THE HOLDOUTS IN THAT WHEN SHE
WON RE-ELECTION THIS MONTH, SHE
JUST WON RE-ELECTION.
546 VOTES.
SHE IS TAKING THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL RISK HERE, YOU COULD
ARGUE.
THEY JUST SENT HER BACK TO
CONGRESS.
DOES SHE CARE?
THAT'S THE A QUESTION FOR HER.
MOST OF THESE REPUBLICANS WON
BIG.
LET'S COME DOWN TO OKLAHOMA.
YOU HAVE CONGRESSMAN-ELECT HERE
JOSH FRISCH, AND 72.4% OF THE
VOTE.
THE COUNTRY MIGHT NOT LIKE
WHAT'S HAPPENING, THE CHAOS ON
THE FLOOR.
HE GOT 72% OF THE VOTE AND HE
THINKS HE IS SAFE.
LET'S MOVE AROUND THE COUNTRY A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SCOTT PERRY OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS IS ONE OF THOSE WHO IS IN
A BIT OF A NIPPY DISTRICT, A
SAFE, BUT NOT BLOWOUT REPUBLICAN
DISTRICT.
HE GOT 54% OF THE VOTE IN THE
ELECTION 60 DAYS AGO.
IS THIS A RISK?
HE HAS DECIDED IT'S WORTH
TAKING.
STILL A SOLID REPUBLICAN
DISTRICT, BUT NOT BY A BLOWOUT
MARGIN.
YOU COME DOWN TO MARYLAND AND
YOU SEE ANDY HARRIS AGAIN.
IF YOU WANT TO ROUND OUT, THIS
IS A SOLID REPUBLICAN DISTRICT.
NOT A 60% OR 70% DISTRICT, BUT
ANDY HARRIS THINKS HE CAN BE
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT, ANTI-LEADER,
ANTI-INSTITUTION.
PICK THE TERM YOU LIKE THERE,
AND THAT IS WHAT IS INTERESTING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP AND YOU
PULL IT OUT, MOST OF THESE ARE
SAFE REPUBLICANS.
YES, THEY'RE DEFYING THEIR
LEADERSHIP, AND THEY MAY BE
EMBARRASSING THEIR PARTY.
THEY MAY BE EMBARRASSING THE
INSTITUTION.
THEY MIGHT BE IGNORING THE
NATIONAL WILL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, JAKE, BUT WHEN THEY LOOK
AT THE DISTRICTS BACK HOME, AND
WE'LL GO TO ILLINOIS NOW.
WE HAD CONGRESSMAN DAVIS ON.
FORMER CONGRESSMAN DAVIS.
HE WAS BEATEN BY MARY MILLER.
SHE HAD DONALD TRUMP'S
ENDORSEMENT.
SHE HAD 71% OF THE VOTE IN THAT
DISTRICT.
SHE THINKS PEOPLE BACK HOME WILL
SUPPORT HERE.
HE'S THE 21 OF THEM HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE 21 OF THEM,
16 OF THEM RECEIVED DONALD
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT BACK IN
THEIR PRIMARY.
SO T